in today's video i'm going to give you
10 of the best gift ideas for animal
crossing fans
look it's no secret that people love
animal crossing
the latest release for the nintendo
switch continues to sell like crazy
across the globe and some folks are so
passionate about the game they want
no they need some animal crossing merch
in their life
tom nook plush anyone people of the
internet retroarch and tour here and if
we're meeting for the first time
i'm just a dad who loves video games and
the stories they tell we post videos
twice a week here
on youtube and today we're looking at 10
of my favorite gift ideas for the animal
crossing fans in your life
or maybe you're the animal crossing fan
and you want to give some not so subtle
hints to your loved ones
also all of the gifts featured on this
list are 50 or less
and make sure you stick around to the
end where we'll throw in some bonus gift
ideas that are either incredibly rare
or very unique and unfortunately not all
of those are under fifty dollars
but with that let's dive into the list
number one
an animal crossing tote bag here's a
delightful animal crossing tote bag that
features the same design found on the
animal crossing themed nintendo switch
look i'm gonna be honest with you guys
my wife got really excited when she saw
this one
there are multiple pockets and storage
components inside two of the pockets are
open and there's also one zipper
compartment that's great for storing
items such as your cell phone sunglasses
keys etc oh and by the way i'll include
links to all of these items down in the
description below so don't feel like you
need to keep track along the way
number two an animal crossing insulated
water bottle
absolutely love this teal water bottle
that features several of our favorite
animal crossing characters according to
the manufacturer it will keep its
contents cold for up to 24 hours
or hot for up to 12 hours the bottle
also comes with a leak-proof lid and
stainless steel filter for loose leaf
tea
or fruit infusion number three a
nintendo switch carrying case
for anyone who travels with their switch
often a carrying case is a must
and if you're an animal crossing fan
you'll be excited to know nintendo has
just the case for you
the case is a simple teal and white with
the leaf pattern that has appeared
throughout the animal crossing series
you should know they make two versions
of these one for the standard nintendo
switch and one for the nintendo switch
light number four an animal crossing
plush
this is the glorious plush toy or as i
like to call it tom nook pillow
from club mochi mochi i've already done
a full review here on the channel
but you should know you can also get a
version with isabelle an apple
or a leaf there are two different sizes
the mega and the junior so make sure you
click
the correct one and i have to say it is
a very soft and very cuddly plush
number five nintendo switch animal
crossing themed
skins nintendo released a special
edition of the nintendo switch which
featured animal crossing on the dock
and on the joy-cons more on that later
unfortunately this was a limited run and
these are pretty hard to find now at
least
at a decent price the next best thing
making your own animal crossing themed
switch
using skins there are many different
designs for these online but here's one
of my favorites that looks similar to
the official animal crossing themed
switch from nintendo
all right we're halfway through if
you've already seen something you'd love
to have go ahead and give me a thumbs up
on this video as we move on to number
six
a makeup bag look another one here that
made my wife really excited when she
took a look i mean for real how adorable
is this
i picked one here that strays away from
that traditional leaf pattern and gives
us a bit more personality
you'll also find several fan favorite
characters featured including brewster
tortimer gulver and more number seven
animal crossing amiibo
if your friend or loved one enjoys
collecting trinkets or toys it's hard to
go wrong with the official
amiibo pack from nintendo now this is
the series three pack which features
rhys
cyrus and kk slider if you're interested
in amiibo though you'll usually need to
act fast because nintendo discontinues
them after a time
there are also several different animal
crossing amiibo out there so if you're
looking for another character just
search their name and amiibo to see what
you can find
number eight a backpack i really liked
this simple animal crossing backpack
from controller gear
this style is my favorite but there are
three different variants to pick from
there's this light blue with the various
tom nook logos a bright teal with the
standard leaf pattern
and one with a bold fruit pattern one
thing to note here is that this is not
a full-sized backpack so make sure you
check the dimensions on it first to see
if it will hold everything that you need
it to hold
number nine apparel at first i was just
going to do
t-shirts here but then i quickly
realized there are so many fantastic
animal crossing apparel options
out there for starters i love these
socks right here
there's also this incredible tom nook
beanie and finally i also mentioned
t-shirts so here are some of my favorite
t-shirts that i came across
online now before we get to number 10 if
you found any items on this list that
you would like
as a gift go ahead and let me know down
in the comments below
and if you appreciate the work we do
here and you'd like to support the
channel then hit that subscribe button
and click the notification bell so you
won't miss any of our weekly videos
and now for number 10 an animal crossing
switch controller
this controller from power a is
officially licensed by nintendo and
again
features the teal color along with kk
slider there's also another version
that's more of a natural green color
with timmy and tommy nook
as the featured characters okay so we
teased some super rare mega gifts in the
beginning
maybe you're saying the gifts so far
aren't unique enough retro they're not
special enough i need to go
big well now is the time to go big
let's start with the one we mentioned
briefly already the animal crossing
themed
nintendo switch at the time of recording
this video there's one of these listed
on amazon for more than five hundred
dollars despite the manufacturer's
suggested retail price of 2.99
these special editions are always
limited runs for nintendo so there's
really no way of knowing if these will
ever be available again for the 299
price tag
you can keep an eye on websites like
amazon ebay craigslist or maybe even a
local used game shop if you have your
heart set on one
who knows you just might get lucky or
maybe you want to pay 500
no doubt it's a beautiful piece of
hardware with a custom dock special
joy-con colors and even animal crossing
themed images on the back of the switch
console itself
all right if you're saying that's way
out of my price range let's look for
some
cheaper but still unique gifts for
animal crossing fans
then how about these 3d printed planters
i actually came across these in an etsy
shop called cami
3d prints now i've done some 3d printing
before myself and i have to say this is
incredible work here there are several
different styles and color options
plus there's a storage box made in the
design of an animal crossing fossil
just brilliant in fact etsy is a
fantastic place if you're looking for a
really unique animal crossing gift
many of the items there are hand made
and just not something you'll typically
find at places like amazon or target
hopefully i've given you more than
enough gift ideas for all the animal
crossing fans
in your life thank you so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon